foreign
[Music]
happy Thursday everybody welcome back to
the data science hangout if it's your
first time joining us to here today it's
so nice to meet you I'm Rachel thanks
for spending your Thursday with all of
us
um and so the hangout is our open space
to chat about data Science Leadership
questions you're facing and getting to
hear what's going on in the world of
data across different Industries
so if this is your first time here we
are here every Thursday at the same time
the same place
and if you're watching this recording on
YouTube later you can also add it to
your calendar if you want to join us
virtually here on Zoom as well
um Curtis I want to make sure that I
made you a co-host so you can help me
with the waiting room as people are
coming in here okay awesome
um but together we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment for
everybody so we'd love to hear from
everyone no matter your years of
experience titles industry or languages
even that you work in
and so every week at the hangout I'm
joined by a different leader from the
community who joins us to share their
experience and answer questions from you
all
so it is totally okay to just listen in
if you want but there's also three ways
you can jump in and ask questions or
provide your own perspective on certain
topics
so you can raise your hand on zoom and
I'll be sure to be on the lookout here
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and put a little star next to it if it's
if it's something you want me to read
out loud instead or else I'll just
calling you to jump in here and join the
party but third we also have a slider
link where you can ask questions
anonymously and I see Hannah just shared
that right as I said it thank you but
I'm so excited to be joined by my
co-host today Andy Nunes Brewster Andy
is the EMS and Trauma research analyst
at Oregon health authority
and Andy I'd love to have you jump in
here and uh introduce yourself share a
little bit about your role and also
something you like to do outside of work
too sure okay
um so I've been with the Oregon Health
Authority since January of 2020 in this
role
um I work with a team that
um coordinates the Emergency Medical
Services throughout the state of Oregon
and so our program licenses Healthcare
professionals who are First Responders
including EMTs and paramedics of all
kind all all shades and
um
and we also regulate ambulance services
um we we have a data system for
electronic patient care records for
field responses so ambulance calls that
that do patient care or transport a
patient every one of those patient
records is in a repository that we get
that data comes in
practically real time we have all those
within 48 Hours of an event and then we
also have several time-sensitive
emergency Registries that we manage
including trauma and cardiac arrest and
stroke
um some of those have Integrations with
the EMS data
um and one of the things I'm really
excited about getting to work on is uh a
project with the Oregon Department of
Transportation where we're looking at
the feasibility of interoperability
between the various EMS data sets that
we have and crash data and so that
that's really exciting too and then
outside of work
um I do play a couple of musical
instruments
from time to time that's a topic that
comes up often in this space and I have
a couple of kids one of whom is about to
move into a dorm at the University of
Oregon in Eugene and we just got to take
him there for um
a couple of orientation sessions and I'm
excited about that he's sort of
interested in data science which I'm
you know crossing my fingers but also
like you know go have fun and have an
adventure and then I also have a
two-year-old
um or soon to be two-year-old so
um it's daycare and college at the same
time for me so I'm happy to have a a
permanent government position
at this time so
you are busy you're very busy yes thanks
uh thank you so much Andy for joining us
I I was thinking back to when we first
got to chat one-on-one and I think it
was because you were building up your
own Community internally
when we first got to chat one-on-one so
I'd love to learn more about that
experience and
what led you to start an internal group
as we're waiting for questions to come
in from from everybody here yeah uh so
and I'm correcting a couple of um uh
acronyms you know if folks if I started
peppering the acronyms I'll try to I'll
try to throw those in the chat too so
yeah the um our community group really
rose out of
um a couple of sections got together the
injury and violence prevention section
and the EMS
um folks in my program
and we wanted to do some training in uh
in our
um relating to kind of upskilling the
team to be able to collaborate and
um
and really we were working on a
procurement for for posit for Enterprise
Solutions so that we can use connect and
um and and do more with the data that we
have
um and so out of this training
um we ended up creating a teams group so
our whole organization our primary way
of communicating with each other is you
know email through Outlook and then chat
through teams and we have lots of
channels that support various working
groups and so there was a team channel
that was created for that our studio
Academy cohort
and after the 10 weeks of us together we
all felt like we just wanted to share
everything we we had learned with
everyone else and so we opened up the
group to everybody and it the first week
we had there was so there was eight of
us to start with we had about six people
join in that first week when we finished
and said let's just invite everyone and
let's share what we've learned
uh the next month there was about 40
people in that group and by the second
month we had over 100 people in that
group and that was then that's only word
of mouth
there isn't anyone running the group
right now we have it's all sort of like
we just get together and and what do
people want what do people need what can
folks bring who can we find to help
bring that
um and so it's it's fairly organic and
we're doing a little bit of work now to
try to make it a little more formal but
it's still very much a work in progress
that's great so it all started with
those people who are the Academy playing
together yeah with the academy cohort I
figured it'd probably be helpful for
anybody who hasn't heard of
what Academy is to just explain what
that process was the team went through
too
sure
um so we uh we learned about it through
the website and then got in touch with
with
um the folks at posit and learns that
it's it's 10 weeks where we get them
where our group is assigned a mentor and
we get a we get uh some healthcare data
to work with
um and we go through some tutorial
modules some of this is asynchronous
some of this we could choose to work
together
um it was really kind of up to the group
how to manage getting through the
tutorial materials and then we would do
a um uh an exercise each week where you
reproduce
um something right either a table or a
way to clean the data and arrange it or
a visualization and then from their
build on it on your own right to to
something to expand upon that that topic
that week and so our group really
it got a couple things out of that
experience
um sort of
drops the barriers and some of the
initial hesitation about sharing code
with one another
and we learned how to
support each other in improving code and
how to
um
it's not just about speaking
um you know kindly or you know
sandwiching your your critique with some
positive things like it's it's more than
that it's about understanding where each
other is in the learning process and
really helping each other
um you know achieve our goals
and and so there's a lot of a lot of
learning how to listen to each other too
so that was really I I felt that was
really a really great thing to Come Away
with
that's awesome I I bet there's something
to
learn from that experience too like you
had this both knit group of people who
were already working together who helped
build this community and that's probably
helped to make it successful too
I see yeah oh sorry you go ahead Andy no
I was just gonna say and and one of the
references that I um that I've been
using personally and just sort of
guiding
um uh my role in this is a book by
uh see it's that's Joss bacon or I could
grab it real quick it's um it's called
The Art of community
um and uh the author is
um someone from the Linux
community and and so a lot of uh the
content from this book and the approach
from this book has been kind of folded
into the Linux Foundation
um uh culture and um and so you know
anything that I've ever done that
touches Linux foundation work has just
felt so
um
so intentionally inclusive
and just oriented in a way that I feel
just really strongly to you know want to
align with it and so
um so I've been doing a little work on
my own to try to
um steer my participation in that that
direction anyway that's great thank you
um I'm gonna jump over to some of the
questions here in the chat and I'd like
to see the conversation happening too
Ted I think you had a question about the
the group yeah I mean well Andy and I
know each other so hey Andy hi Ted so
one of the things that I've heard a lot
with I like starting these groups is
people really want to want to
participate but they're so busy like so
um I found that one of the routes to
kind of improving that is to get
sponsors among leadership
um do you have any experience with that
um no that's a really interesting idea
and I'm curious about what the role of
the sponsor really would be because I
would want to be able to articulate that
to I I'm in my head it sounds like kind
of like um mentoring like someone who's
in a leadership position that can say
you know go ahead and participate
because we're getting this value back
out of it or some something along those
lines and then folks feel like they have
the space to ask for that right yeah I
think I think just someone who can
formally say that for like you know an
entire group that it's okay to spend
time on this
um I think also it's just people like
people who are willing like if your
supervisor is willing for you to
dedicate time to it
um the organization yeah things like
that
yeah I mean right now
um one of the things we're working on is
getting leadership and when I say
leadership I mean the Oregon Health
Authority director's office like our
overall our agency leadership is getting
um getting some support there we've got
a couple of
um Advocates right now
um but but when I mean formalizing the
support like having something where
someone's got a project they're working
on and they're spending time supporting
this this community
um and so that's
um that's coming from not just you know
our folks and in public health that
that's coming from all over the agency
um so
I think we're heading in that direction
but the idea of sponsors sounds really
interesting to me it's also similar to
where it kind of
I guess it has a different
um
level of where the in the power
hierarchy that it's
that it's using but I also like the idea
of having sort of like a um
Mentor Network
right where I know of a few folks who
are working on some things that I'm
trying to learn and also I can share
back with folks who are trying to learn
some of the things that I'm working on
um and we've we've talked about you know
maybe ways to do something like that
uh
with the group as well
really it's about fostering connections
and creating a culture of inclusivity
where everyone can do data science
anyone here who's working with data
whether that's
you know language and and surveys and
qualitative information or it's you know
our quantitative Epi stuff that everyone
is welcome everyone is here to learn
we're here to support each other
um few other questions coming in on
this learning process for your team and
I see Ben ask a question about around
git Ben do you want to jump in here
yeah we um there's a lot of interest in
R but then there's this
obviously backbone of Education which is
git which I'm struggling introducing to
them because a lot of the analysts and
data scientists you know they're not
quote-unquote Engineers
um so just curious if you address that
hurdle if you've seen it and if the
process you went through helped right so
there's a couple of things happening
with with our access to get right now
sorry I just bumped my chair
um and we have limited access to it at
this point there's ongoing conversations
between it and
data engineers and the informatics
side of the house where
informatics is
can you know convincing and showing the
business case that we need to be able to
do devops
um that's not been understood you know
by
it in the past and so
um so we're we're trying to get access
to you know git and right now we can use
Azure devops but not many of us are most
of us are more familiar with GitHub
um so most of that learning is really
focused out of all of us as state
employees have access to the a resource
at the state of Oregon library it's a
library that's part of the state
government and it's
so it provides resources to State
agencies and one of our resources is the
O'Reilly learning platform
and so we can go on to O'Reilly and take
any of those asynchronous courses and
live courses and and
um you know we're supported in in
learning through through that Resource
as well
um and I've taken a handful of uh like
Brent Laster I think does some some git
courses through O'Reilly that have been
really helpful like just learning
command blanket
um but you know it's
even the part where we're convincing
folks to you know you do want to spend
this kind of time learning R we have to
also have the discussion about how
learning is part of your productivity
right and that if we're not learning
we're actually you know we're actually
losing ground on building capacity for
our future work because we're not going
to ever have less work to do
right
um and so
a lot of what we're doing is trying to
find ways to be more efficient with the
work that we do but as soon as we're
doing you know we save oh I automated
this report and I saved myself you know
10 hours every quarter from re-running
this report well those 10 hours are like
as soon as you say that like that that
time is going to another project that
also really needs to get done right so
um so we do have to say well even though
you have that pressure
your learning is part of the
productivity and so there's time that
that time that you're spending there
isn't just you know there's meeting your
learning objectives is part of you know
what we're here to do
and it's just as part of much part of
your outcome right or output
um
any other questions on the learning I
could pivot to another one of these
questions about the data or yeah
I'll uh I'll handle the questions I have
the deposit team around helping me yeah
okay thanks
um but I see Alan you had asked a
question around the data landscape do
you want to jump in here yeah sure hi
Andy um uh so like big picture I'm super
fascinated at how like I should conceive
of Emergency Services as being like this
whole other like ring of service
providers in the medical like landscape
and I'm curious how they interact like
with with you as an agency and then like
tactically how does how does their data
become come into your landscape and then
I know I'm sort of rolling on and on but
I'm really curious like what kinds of
problems are you solving with that data
is it about like research application is
it about is it about where people are in
terms of location like distribution of
services and and that kind of stuff
um I realize there's there's a bunch
there whatever is kind of interesting in
there that you want to speak to I'd love
to hear about
yeah so um so our our program is the
regulatory body We're The Regulators
um folks that provide these services are
licensed through our office and the and
their standards of care in in place for
providing those services and we collect
the data for that to be able to do
quality improvement and to do compliance
work
um so we we do compliance for uh for
ambulance services
um and part of that is a you know
reviewing your records and are you
completing
um your your patient care records you
know are you
um appropriately checking the right
boxes for you know particular cases
um so there's and then we and we also do
that for trauma hospitals as well so
certified Trauma Centers um that data is
used to you know verify aspects of the
of the patient care itself and also
verify aspects of their performance
Improvement
um because all
um trauma hospitals are required to have
an ongoing performance Improvement
program
so so essentially the the data is used
for compliance and safety
um but it is also used for
um
in the fields it can be used for
decision making in
um in patient care
um so one of the problems that we've
tackled recently is documentation of
weight
for
patients who receive a weight-based
medication
in the field and so this is especially
important in Pediatrics
and
um our program was able to collect data
to see you know when there's a
weight-based medication that is
administered in the field how often is
the weight documented in the record we
developed a performance metric out of
this and we did a letter writing
campaign to our ambulance agencies and
now
uh our expectation was that this would
be you know a pretty conventional thing
we'd see a 20 response rate or something
super low but it was it was off it was
off the chart we went from uh you know
somewhere in the
you know below our threshold to almost a
hundred percent within like a couple of
months of implementing of that letter
writing campaign and sharing back with
everyone their performance metric and
where they were compared to where we are
as the state and we're now doing
multiple performance metrics
um and so we do them for both EMS and
Trauma a lot of that is on our website
um
so I hope I touched on some of that in
terms of how the data gets to us
um we actually manage uh we have third
party vendors
who uh provide uh electronic patient
care record software
um and we have so we have a vendor who
provides a software for our
um
electronic medical records systems and
um and then also for our our licensing
management system and then also for the
trauma registry and the the folks that
do the EMS system also provide our
stroke and Care registry Integrations as
well and so we do a lot of vendor
management and a lot of
uh user support between our users and
things that we can do with the vendor
but things we also have to ask the
vendor to do for us you know
awesome thank you yeah that touched on
like a whole bunch of stuff I'm
interested in it sounds like a neat
landscape of like complex systems and
then your ability to pull like
performance things out of that data and
address it directly I think is really
cool it's super neat to think about
thanks yeah and and R is really crucial
to that whole workflow because without
it you know we're using the vendor's
tools to assess how those software are
performing but that's not always even
possible and so having a way to you know
pull data from one table look at where
things are moving into a submissions
table from from the other side look at
what was received on the other side I've
uh since joining this team I'm learning
XML and hl7 and some of these other you
know ways of moving data between systems
that
um you know it's definitely not where I
thought I was headed but it's super
exciting
I want to make sure I jump over to some
of the slido questions too so just to
remind everybody if you joined a little
bit later you can also ask questions
anonymously on slido but one of the and
Hannah we'll share that in the chat but
one of the link uh questions there was
what kinds of governance or policies do
you have for using R across your agency
so for example deployment guidelines or
software upgrade policies approved
packages
yeah that is really Loosely defined at
the moment
um at the moment it's R is only
supported at the
um
at the individual desktop level and you
have to go through an exceptions process
to be able to download it and then
everyone is on their own for managing
their own package libraries
um it's pretty
um you know in incongruous in terms of
being able to collaborate there have you
have to do a lot of your own lift
to ensure that you know that everyone
can open and run the same projects if
that's what you're trying to do
[Music]
um
and so we're really trying to work
towards having a
um an Enterprise supported solution
um and that's been a long haul there's a
lot of grant money that's going in to
support it but there's also bureaucracy
and transparency that you know that we
are in that we have to we just have
processes we have to go through and so
um it takes longer than we think it
should sometimes but
um you know we're spending taxpayer
money and
we also have Grant grantees or you know
grant funders that we have to report
back to and so
um
yeah just trying to figure out how to do
that but right now it's not very
coordinated
I'm about to ask this question I haven't
formulated it in my head so let me come
out weird sure okay I feel like you were
you were very creative with getting her
around some of that to at least push
things forward with with being able to
train new users and bring together this
community and and I think it's worth
talking about that too like you've maybe
hit Roblox and in one way but went in a
different direction
yeah I mean
um
so I guess it's it's a matter of
I guess accepting the things that we can
control and focusing on the areas where
we have some
agency and so
um you know if we're told you can't use
that tool right now you have to go
through this process of approval that is
you know 12 steps deep and
14 different programs are going to touch
that approval process I'm kind of
exaggerating here but it's it's a lot
and and
um and you know for
a lot of really good reasons a lot of
legal reasons too
um and
at each one of these roadblocks we just
say Okay so we're not able to move
forward with with this in this way
now
we're going to try to keep moving in
this direction what can we do with the
resources and the time that we have and
then we brainstorm a little bit and and
see what ideas are in the room
and then just kind of go from there so a
lot of this isn't isn't me doing it I'm
just asking questions
um and then I'm you know doing what I
can to support folks in in us you know
following up and supporting each other
thank you
and I see some of my colleagues are in
here popping some comments in the chat
too so I love that some folks have been
able to to join and and share as well
because really I did want to bring more
of the the group experience here and not
just you know my own thing
um I might share a couple of shiny app
links for some injury data just to give
these folks some
some Kudos because the learning with
them has been really awesome and um and
I'm really proud of the work we're doing
together
absolutely if you want to call anybody
up here
I see Abigail you had a question a bit
earlier
um regarding the the training piece do
you want to ask that yeah so I've worked
with the government too and I would
never suggest like don't train people
because they'll leave like that's
terrible but I love you um but like how
do you think about the nutrition piece
and when you're training people in some
skills that will make them able you know
more able to leave possibly for more
money how do you think about supporting
them and what you can do to keep them
after they're trained up
that's a really good question and I'm
not a manager so I don't really know
what they do just to keep people
engaged
even without the learning
right just the fact that we're doing
this work
it pays more in the private sector
like it just does
um especially for folks who want to live
in Portland like you know where where
Portland has a higher there's areas in
the state that have a much higher cost
of living than other areas in the state
and for a lot of us we're working
remotely and so there was you know a lot
of folks decided to move to smaller
towns because the cost of living and
inflation just you know really kind of
took a lot of progress
from you know folks in public you know
in public sector pay
um in the last couple years so
uh
I don't really have a good answer for
that what I the only thing I will say is
in terms of what we can do for each
other on a team
is that um
is creating the culture that that keeps
people engaged and that
makes people feel like they're a part of
something larger right and feeling
connected
um one of the things we hear a lot from
uh folks in this group is I feel like
I'm the only one on my team using R and
100 people after two months just is
showing us that that's not really
necessarily the case that there are
other people potentially using it or
even wanting to learn and we're just not
able to sh to connect with one another
and so I think
having these communities is one of these
ways that we can
start to engage folks but also um
I'm not sure that there's a really
easy answer for that because of course
folks are you know willing to or you
know we have agency to work for whomever
we want to and and public sector just
has to
I don't know it's I think nonprofits
have this have a similar uh you know a
similar challenge in that like you want
to support your people to learn and grow
and you want to keep them and
sometimes that means we have to pay them
what they think they're worth
so like that's just a challenge of how
to how to make that fit
um yeah it's not a good answer but no I
mean it's right
um yeah no it's hard it's something
really struggles with with like
something authors too it's tough to keep
people cyber security that's a big one
they just leave
yeah yeah
um so I don't know maybe maybe we start
training people knowing that um the if
we're only supporting them in in growing
in skills and not supporting and
everything else that that's just what's
gonna happen and then you gotta plan for
that I don't know I mean
part of what keeps me here is that our
organization really does focus on racial
Justice we do focus on Equity work we do
focus on these other pieces that make me
feel like I'm contributing to the
community in a way that's beyond just
improving our you know our health care
System
um and that's part of what keeps me here
isn't that is the quote like what if I
train them and they leave but what if
you don't and they stay
yeah right yeah
um let's jump over to uh one other
question from slido was Oregon is known
for great Community responder programs
how does this impact your work
um
yeah I think that there's a lot going on
in Oregon with
expanding community paramedicine and
um
having
um support for Behavioral Health crises
that isn't
you know the first person responding is
a is a behavioral health specialist and
not a medical
provider right so there's there's some
um
and uh
there sorry I'm a little distracted by
some of the comment fun comments going
on in the chat it is really hard no it's
fun it's no it's totally it's all it's
all fun
let's keep it going
um yeah and so like
as Regulators we kind of have to
be
you know we have to be really clear with
here's the line at which if you're doing
patient care you have to have patient
care record systems you know these are
the rules right we have to be really
clear with what the rules are and then
if you're you know not if you're not uh
providing those Services then
you know there's there's certainly ways
in which our
um are
advisory groups are involved in those
other groups so like Mountain Rescue has
a person who sits on our EMS State
committee for example so you know like
they're not necessarily an ambulance
transporting agency but they're
certainly involved in a lot of different
types of you know
um events and and so
um so those folks kind of get involved
in our um in our community groups we
have several we have Regional trauma
advisory boards we have a state trauma
Advisory Board and a state EMS Advisory
Board we have a couple of data working
groups that we
um run with uh you know folks that are
kind of our data super users
um in both EMS and Trauma and so
really in terms of community involvement
we're more of like providing information
and helping connect resources and not
doing a whole lot of the like the
community's doing the work and then
coming to us and saying hey we're seeing
this what can we do and we try to put
together some resources and work with
them
thank you
um I see Jared you had a question a bit
earlier about working with HIPAA data do
you want to jump in here hi Eddie sorry
yeah I uh I think for me it's like I've
you speak on so many things that I I've
dealt with but uh how do you manage to
like on a public health level do you
talk with other
States or even at a national level to
like
like collaborate on future kind of
future initiatives or future endeavors
where oops where those like you know
when when I was in my role like HIPAA
was not as much of a concern with a lot
of the data we were we were collating
and kept bringing together but I feel
like in your role it's got to be a lot
more uh an important like kind of staple
that may prevent collaboration from
happening so I just didn't know if you
could kind of speak on how that all has
kind of come into your fold and how
you've managed it
yeah so for the most part our vendors
um are required to be compliant under a
handful of things hip is just one of
them right and there's other cyber
security things that they have to be
compliant with and
um so so we're
very much like it's very much part of
our data governance
right is that where all of our systems
are compliant with those requirements
um it definitely also comes into play
when with our
um fulfilling data requests
um
but it's at this point it's not so much
an obstacle as just part of the
framework that we're operating under
um and so
uh you know we we have to use secure
you know secure tools for doing any data
sharing when we're doing our compliance
work with hospitals for example right
and so that's
um
you know I have a cyber security team
that I call them and say hey this is
what we're doing are we good
and um and there's either so there's
it's a it's a huge team effort
um the HIPAA stuff is really just part
is just part of our data governance it's
it's just um
uh yeah it says
it just seems like it's part of
whatever we're doing and I don't really
have to worry about that so much as much
as
I've just got the rules you know the
rules that I follow and that's how we're
that's how we operate probably you know
not not a really great question for that
but
all right answer I mean sorry not a not
a great answer for your question but the
um
no it makes sense I think it's it's just
about knowing like you brought up that
you have you you know like kind of a
cyber security department that allows
you to like be your
conscience when it comes to sharing data
and doing things like that because we it
was more of like in my role it was more
like
if you don't feel comfortable then don't
do it but how do you manage that to a
degree when you're trying to work across
multiple public health organizations to
try and uh find some level of
consistency or standardization how
you're doing things and so then that
became a bigger a bigger conversation a
bigger problem so I just was kind of
curious how Oregon I never got that far
that far to the coast but I was like I
wonder how big this could be made I know
you know there's some governance at the
national level but could this be an okay
thing of like hey if you're having a lot
of issues in Oregon maybe you know
Washington or maybe California is having
you know similar things and you guys can
kind of talk and collaborate to uh to
come up with with answers if that makes
sense yeah and we we certainly do that
there's um so there are national
standards for EMS data
um I I dropped a link in the chat for
the the Nemesis the organization that
that handles all that there's also
National Data standards for for trauma
and definitely like one of the things
that I'm I feel like I'm really good at
is like I get to a situation where like
hmm this is something I haven't done
before and I have a sense of what I'm
gonna do but I want to talk to somebody
who's done this before
I have no problems going onto a bunch of
websites trying to find my counterparts
in other states you know I've connected
to folks in Iowa
um in fact this weekend at the Cascadia
art conference I was able to connect
with some of our counterparts that
Washington
state of Washington Department of Health
um and so yeah definitely
um our the data manager for my program
is right now at a conference for
National EMS data managers like there's
you know there's um
there certainly is uh supported a
national level and we are
really trying to connect with other our
users in those at the in those places
um because the data does have national
standards
um we've got a lot of our code that you
know is works with those data
dictionaries that you know we're using
for doing things that are both human and
machine readable and we would love to
share some of that with other folks that
are our users and so I'm packaging it
thank you Ted that's
that's my big thing that I'm working on
right now is building some internal
packages and I'm I need to learn how to
do better testing and and all that so
anybody else learning that stuff right
now I'm
I'm game for for study study Buddies
awesome
when I when I see
comment in the chat with like a ton of
replies on it I feel like that indicates
that something good we should chat about
right now
um and so Eugene I see you had put a
comment into the chat around
um
like issues with working with certain
apis and wondered if you wanted to like
jump in here and just share what you're
experiencing and see if we can maybe
figure something out here as a group
um I I guess what I what I was bringing
up is the challenge of you know feeling
alone working with r I am totally the
the one-man team three-quarter stack ml
engineer uh I'll call it and I could be
full stack but we you know we don't have
a good sort of like posit
um shiny server you know Enterprise
solution where I could just put my stuff
up there so
um I'm sort of you know clunking through
with open source uh shiny server and
allowing one person at a time to use my
my app for the one use case but anyway I
have HTTR you know is is a very well
full featured API HTTP request uh
package and I went through some issues
trying to figure out why I was
automatically being dropped by I'm also
in government I'm a government
contractor so I'm going from the VA I'm
pulling from Vista which is this monster
monster Monster database and there's a
few layers of abstraction between it and
we built or I should say some people in
our company built a wonderful uh soap
API you know standard that allows me to
do multiple types of requests and all um
yeah
um throwing in my arguments and you know
there's an iteration you kind of have to
do one thing to open your connection get
the cookies you got to do another thing
to follow up and select your patient and
then you gotta select you know what you
want to do with that page or how you
want to get that patient's data and
these things depending on the time of
day uh it drops at night but it doesn't
drop during the day or you know
something with their real shoddy so uh I
keep you know texting back and forth hey
this is what I'm getting what what do
you need to see to help me help you
debug why this connection keeps dropping
and it just turned into do well the
people that are using this are using you
know python they're doing it with this
request package I don't know what you're
doing I don't know how it works I don't
know what HTTR is and you must you have
to change to a fully featured API
request you know type of package if
you're if I'm going to continue
supporting you period and that like I've
always had good interactions with this
person until this just really broke the
I'm like okay fine I'll do it all myself
you know so it was that statement I
don't know if there's the right question
for how to do it but I am building a
little r markdown report right where I'm
going to extract every little freaking
thing that httpr can produce from a the
request object that comes back and I
will put it out in PDF format and hand
it over and just say please go figure
out what to do because you know I I
don't know what else to do from a
dialogue point of view I'm going to just
produce technical documentation errors
and send it right back to them and say I
need help
feels like this is the
communication collaboration piece that
we've talked about through some other
Hangouts at one point or another too but
um I'm curious if anybody has
experienced something similar or has uh
maybe some some ideas to share
and Andy I think you were going to start
with sharing something too no I was just
gonna say I'm I'm having some uh I'm
feeling some of my feelings are being
reflected in the chat right now so I'll
just say that
um
uh
yeah I'm gonna agree that it sounds like
there's a communication piece there the
layer to that in addition to the
technical aspect
um if I had a question about API stuff
and why something isn't working for me I
would ask Ted
I'm just saying what would I do in this
situation if I found myself
um struggling with a with an API
um I you know I just I guess
um
we
if I found a limit where I'm I'm finding
that someone is running out of ideas for
helping me work through a technical
problem
um I guess there's
you know I don't
uh pointing out all the things that are
wrong with something someone's working
on is probably not going to help them be
motivated to help you fix what you're
trying to do with the thing they're
working on so
um I try to
adjust how I'm seeing it and say okay
we're on the same team
here
and we just start seeing this from a
different you know it's the elephant I'm
seeing the I'm seeing the the trunk only
and I'm trying to get to this other part
of it and the and the person doesn't see
how what what it is that I'm seeing
and so maybe the process of doing all
that documentation
you'll find something else there that
you didn't see before and then sharing
that process with this other person
um might also open the door I don't know
it's my memory is being triggered back
to a hangout with Matt Frazier when he
was talking about like non-violent
Communication in that book
um
but talking about how like when you get
into this position like listen for needs
and express needs so starting with like
just explaining I'm trying to do this
for the organization like like I'm
trying to help the company this is why I
think this is valuable like do you agree
that this is valuable like taking the
technical part of it but like getting
buy-in first that what you're trying to
do is going to be helpful and then
saying like in order to do that
I have these needs that aren't being met
like how can we get to that next step
um I'll share the recording here in the
chat in a second too
another Harold we'll shift gears here
but I figured because there was so much
conversation there on on that one
um that would be a good one to dive into
if anybody had other thoughts you wanted
to share there feel free to raise your
hand to I think Abigail you had shared a
few things there no I'm good I don't I
for some reason it feels better to say
you should use Python and chat then it
doesn't add in chat I don't know
okay well well we can keep the
conversation happening in chat too
um but Sanjay I saw you had asked a
question about EMS
um
and the data formats do you want to jump
in here
yeah so nationally in U.S you've got a
lot of data integration obviously across
hospitals and what I heard you saying
and these was that you put vendors and
you got EMS systems implemented uh
separately for each hospital or each
state is that like that if if it is
separate then how do you integrate the
data across States
that's a really really great question so
yes each state implements the national
state data standard in the way that they
want to do it so California a lot of
larger states that have a lot more
hospitals Trauma Centers than
um than Oregon does they tell everybody
okay you're required to do this data
you're required to submit this data to
the state here's the state repository go
out and get your software and send it to
us
because we're The Regulators you know
um and so that's really left up to those
organizations they go and they they
procure software they those vendors
um set up you know data data pipelines
between the the databases
um
and then and then it works right
supposedly I mean that's that's the idea
um what ends up happening is because of
um
uh requirements for data validation and
and
um which a lot of this is built into the
soft those that software
um
and requirements for
certain hospitals uh level ones level
twos and level there's four levels of of
trauma uh accreditation and those are
based on the levels of trauma care that
can be provided at those hospitals and
so
um everything but your level four is
on the national level
um is recommended that they provide that
data to not only their state agencies
but the National Database and so those
software vendors that are supporting
um that provide the the service to
either
um uh State agencies like our program or
the hospitals they have you know widgets
within there that provide that do that
National Data validation and submissions
for for National Data
with the most recent version of the EMS
data there is now a data field that is a
universally unique identifier for the
record itself not the patient but the
record
and that can now be linked at the
national level to the the trauma record
and so there there's an effort now
within the data standards to be able to
link these at a national level
um that work is ongoing
um it's Oregon was I think the seventh
or ninth state to adopt the new standard
and start to implement this this uuid
which means that our our
interoperability between EMS data and
Trauma data
um you know like we really have to focus
on that
um when when the linkage doesn't work
that uuid doesn't move between the data
systems and you know and and we're gonna
we're gonna just have for this first
year or two
um some uh some data that isn't quite as
completely linked as we want it to but
it's just a matter of improving that as
we go
Oregon does provide the service the the
software for all of the hospitals
they're allowed to use that for for free
they can just um you know we provide
um the technical support
um they can also go and get their own
implementation of an integration between
their Hospital electronic Healthcare
records a couple of our hospitals do
that and then a couple of the hospitals
um have their own system and export data
to us
so it's allotted it's kind of all a lot
of different ways that it happens yeah
thank you yeah thank you very much
um I know that this hour goes by so
quickly
um but we were when we were talking
about Academy in in the beginning
I'd love to see all the the great
feedback that you've shared Andy and and
I was just curious how did you feel
Academy was different from other
training programs that you tried yeah so
the collaboration piece was was big
um because we were
working together on a weekly basis
um you know we were able to
just form these relation these working
relationships with one another in a way
that probably wouldn't have happened if
we were just asynchronously doing
tutorials together
um
and having the mentor
available for answering questions and
um you know that's
also
it's it's not that there's someone who's
like the the teacher
providing this content and we are
you know taking this content in and
doing a thing with it
it was almost like
um having a coach instead right
um and so the group was able to lean
into places where we wanted to learn and
maybe it was outside of the content a
little bit
and they're just I haven't really
experienced that kind of flexibility
with
you know with other other platforms when
you mentioned Mentor I realized I missed
a question from Ben a bit earlier too
Ben do you want to jump in here
I think you asked about like what it
meant to have a defined Mentor yeah I'm
sitting over here showing my face full
of chips sorry
yeah the mentor thing is really
interesting in that
um it's a different role and so I'm more
I'm curious how influential it was
through the process you mentioned coach
but it really is a different aspect to
it and so I was curious how you're
carrying that on and if there is
something that you're looking to in the
future as you develop the community if
there is something you could clearly
Define to the internal team this if you
might build that role with
yeah
um so
I guess the the coach aspect of it
it just feels like there's a slightly
different Power Dynamic than with a
instructor and student and
um it's like
there's a little more
um
the I guess as a learner I'm able to be
a little more self-directed
um then then like I'm here to take a
class I guess
um even though it really is focused on
you know here you're learning goals and
stuff
as far as mentors we haven't really uh
had
I feel like we've we've sort of
rather than leaning on that one Mentor
that we had during that Academy session
we've sort of branched out and developed
a network of mentors
um several of whom are just positive
employees that are here to support us
right
um and so um so we've asked Jeremy Allen
to come and give our group a
um a quarto demo you know
um and I probably could have put
together a quarto demo but like Jeremy's
is really good so having you know having
someone come in and and and kind of step
up to that is has been really great
um
in terms of how we're going to support
each other
you know I think that that's that Mentor
is really just a hat that we can wear
and sometimes I'm the mentor and
sometimes I'm the mentee
right and just
um trying to establish the relationships
where we can
take those hats on and off and I'm not
required all the time to answer
someone's questions right like we we're
all here to get our work done also right
so
um
I think one thing we might try to do as
the group is um is do like some computer
lab uh office hour study hour kind of
things where we can all show up and we
can work on our own things but then we
can be there to sort of support each
other and answer questions like that's
been a thing that I thought would be
um fun and amazing to do
um be nice to figure out how to do that
in a hybrid setting so that you know
folks who are living in other parts of
the state and working in different
programs throughout the state could
still participate and learn with us um
but I haven't quite figured out all the
logistic details on that one
yeah and Jerry Jerry is awesome seeing
some of that in the chat
Jeremy Jeremy is awesome yeah um one
other slider question I saw that just
came in was could you talk a bit more
about the team aspect of the work is the
analytics in the agency centralized or
do teams get put together for specific
projects
that's a really great question there's a
little bit of both so we have a data
team in EMS and
um
there is also a like
like a health policy and analytics
section in division in the in the agency
um where they really are focused on just
like data and statistics
um as it relates to policy and programs
um but
uh and then there's specific like
analytics and informatics teams within
programs like our acute and communicable
disease program has an analytics team
where they've got a data integrator
they've got a data visualization
specialist
um you know they've got
um reporting Specialists who who build
you know some of these dashboards that
injury dashboards and things
um so it's it's kind of a little bit of
both
it's really dependent on the needs of
the program and the resources that the
agency has to kind of support
um where that work is I think there's a
couple of programs that probably really
need analysts and they're you know
working on kind of building that
capacity and stuff thank you so much
Andy yeah
um I feel like we're like standing on
stage and people are chanting for Encore
because like people asking can we have a
bonus hour right now
um so I know people have to drop to
other uh meetings here so I always want
to say thank you all so much for joining
us today and thank you Andy
um I I know you probably have to leave
to another meeting but I can hang around
for a little bit longer if people wanted
to to chat too I just want to say thanks
for this opportunity I get so much from
this group
um when whenever I'm here and even if
I'm like you know having to work on
other stuff and I'm just kind of you
know here to to listen and learn I just
get so much from this group and so it's
just really been awesome to be able to
um you know share back so thank you
I love that thank you so much Andy it's
it's
I can't believe how long we've been
doing these now and like just getting to
actually know people through the hangout
is is awesome yeah it's awesome well
have a great rest of the day everybody
Olivia cat is amazing you need to talk
so I can see your cat right now
oh my gosh I'm so sorry she has been um
oh
he just wants every moment of my time
and he's been jumping onto my laptop and
pressing keys and changing things on my
screen so sorry he did a lot of Zoom
bombing today thank you I just pinned
your video so that I can only see you
right now thank you Andy hi guys
absolutely thanks everybody thanks
everyone have a great rest of the day
take care all right bye everybody
bye Luke I see you're still here did you
have other things you want to chat about
no
I guess my curiosity if Amy still around
is
um are there times where you know we
have an issue with um
our regulatory body in the in LA county
place they have different accounting for
their offload time as opposed to like
the artists in the EHR
so I wonder like just having you guys
have kind of negotiated like when you
have discrepancies depending on who's
recording what
um
so like discrepancies and just um like
we're seeing certain records coming over
and we're not seeing other records or
like actual within the record
discrepancies like the record has this
over here and it's something else in
this system
um the idea is more like when it comes
to like patient offload times
um maybe like the um
maybe the EMS will like start the we'll
start like there we rest your time at a
different point than we would an EMR
so like this they're just saying like
you know the moment they like
pulled into the parking lot is like when
they started and maybe you were saying
it's like the moment they're entered
into the systems or something like that
it's kind of like how do you
kind of back and forth because you know
they'll be like hey you know you're
um you know 15 or 20 minutes over the
ideal and it's like well not according
to what we asked
yeah I wonder
so one of the things that we work on
pretty
um consistently is
um
having a demographics profile from every
vendor that's participating in providing
data to the EMS system and then they're
required to have their system set up
under like really tight specifications
for how each data element is collected
and then mapped to the state registry
and we do
um like
schema validation to ensure that you
know that the date that is shown in your
record is what comes over in our record
and if it's the same time it's actually
the scene time if it's the you know
um transport time it's you know it's uh
and so aside from like working with
those vendors on you know really
drilling into
what information is being stored where
and how that's moving from one system to
another and just really getting into
those details
um like we just have to do that one
vendor at a time sometimes it's one
agency at a time right and we're we're
dealing with you know over 200 agencies
and
a you know half a dozen different
vendors with each of different you know
instance in a different agency so
yeah it's really just
um the data qualities just kind of seems
like a never-ending
uh source of work
it's almost like emergency
but
yeah there was actually one time I think
we figured out that the discrepancies
because like
they were they were not like starting
their route until after their smoke
break
and this is one of the private EMS
companies that like drops off patients
here and we're like
issue but it's not the issue of all the
time yeah yeah
when the data is right but you don't
like what's in the data like that's a
different
situation than a mapping at you the
human elements of the data it was making
me think of the
the Iceland the city of Reykjavik
customer story
they were like why is this data for
who's entering the different pools
across Island across Iceland not mapping
up and it was because when I got really
busy they would just open up the gates
and like let everybody out so it looked
like people who entered the pools were
just staying there they never left yeah
foreign
thank you so much Annie and thanks all
for sticking around here too yeah thanks
everyone bye